welcome back spinal care of nevada who
is the sponsor of this next segment
offers complete chiropractic care and
here to tell us more about their gentle
form of care is dr devin welcome back to
the show hey buddy great to be here it's
great to have you back in studio so
let's talk about it what is nuka okay so
nuka is a very gentle style of
chiropractic you know if you if you've
been to a chiropractor and you like the
twisting cracking popping i'm probably
not the right guy you're not the guy
okay so nuka is a very gentle style
where we adjust the top of the neck
area called your brainstem brainstem
controls everything it's like my wife
tells you what to do where to go how to
do it and i listen
so by getting pressure off that we help
things like headaches migraines neck
pain and by rebalancing the head and
neck it helps everything else go
underneath straight again so even things
like low back pain sciatica burning
nerves into the feet let's see how it
works you brought it in here we've been
watching all summer long with your
segments and now it is in studio we
treat uh kids in the office too they
nickname it the woodpecker
the sound it makes yes yes so this is
the secondary type of uh adjustment we
do we can go into like you know that
hump on the back of people's back yeah
nickname the dowage or something and go
in and tap tap tap tap how about pain
right in between the shoulder blades tap
tap tap if you have degenerative disc
disease where the disc is worn down this
helps open those spaces up right into
the lower back sciatica low back pain
disc problems it's a it feels incredible
doesn't hurt it's very non-invasive and
helps relieve pain now there's people
that have had surgery before they come
see you and they don't need surgery
after the fact
we see people who've been through rods
plates screws um even minor surgeries
have been told hey never go see a
chiropractor but because our techniques
are very gentle non-invasive or the the
md's that refer to us call it low force
we can treat patients who even have rods
plates and screws in their back now yeah
someone just cannot walk right in and
get your services you can you do a
two-day building we're a little more
thorough yes i love that this is great
you're right there so if you're looking
for the stop in get a crack not the
right guy for you so we do a two-day
workup and on the screen this is a nerve
chart which shows if we adjust the
middle back that's the nerve that goes
to the stomach and if you adjust the
upper back that's a nerve that can even
run to the heart and the lungs so i
don't claim to cure breathing problems
and heart problems but if you get the
pressure off of these nerves that can
run everything in the entire body now
what are some of the areas that you
treat you mentioned migraines what are
some if people have symptoms at home
what do you treat so in the two day
workup we're going to examine you from
head to toe you come with neck pain
we're going to check the back too
because that's all part of it so day one
throw history exam consultation we'll
take digital x-rays best type of films
in my field i wish more people would
take them
day two we're gonna go over all the
findings okay and i'm real
straightforward if i can't help someone
i'm gonna get them to the right doctor
if i can we're real up front we're gonna
go over time cost coverage everything
and get to work that's what i like about
you 99 of the time you're going to help
someone but if you can't for some reason
you're not gonna fake it you're gonna
set them to the right spot i love it i
appreciate you coming back in studio dr
david my pleasure for being here one
more time give us a shot okay so the
woodpecker here we're going up the bones
and again we do the two day work up um
normally it's 180
for the first 20 callers we give it to
them for 37
beautiful and just watching you do it it
seems very gentle almost relaxing to
watch this it is
people who are afraid of going to
chiropractors or god forbid have been
hurt at chiropractors or other
physicians offices they come see us
because it's so gentle and safe perfect
thank you dr devin we appreciate it
spinal care nevada they've got two
locations summerlin and henderson and
you can reach them at
702-566-hope that's 4673 or go to
drdevin.com two-day work-up including
digital x-rays for 37 that's normally
180
this is for the first 20 callers not
valid for those eligible for federal
benefits mercedes